[Music]
I really believe that our innovation
will continue to be revolutionary I
really love CSS
[Music]
[Applause]
you 2019
[Music]
CSS account for you is all about
community it's about people now like I
walked into the legislation and then
like you know immediately I have to
person like it's an event about
computers but really it's about the
humans behind me and no detail is
overlooked and it's great as an attendee
that there's you there's nothing to
worry about like having the prayer room
having the quiet room that the pocket
space community lounge it's a space and
its own little stage really to put a
spotlight on people who are doing
positive things in the community this
year at the community lounge we have the
theme of gratitude and we said you know
how has the tech community positively
impacted you I wanted people to come
away thinking what power do I have to do
good and it's it's huge
we can do little things we can do tiny
things that maybe we don't even think
about that have such a huge impact on
people
sometimes I find a paper an old
algorithm that is actually made by a
woman
but many people sometimes even including
me I thought that was actually a man
behind that name we were coming up with
the idea of making an advent calendar of
24 women there are pioneers in in tech
[Music]
and I think about CSS I think it's
creative coding and I try to always to
match the design of just creativity and
playfulness that's why it shows Flavor
Flav and colors and shapes I'm talking
about how to apply the Houdini specs to
your work today in design systems
introducing the sub great value for CSS
screen I'll be talking about community
and its importance
we were the unseen my talk was about
visual testing it was a description of
how our tools have changed the way that
we do a modern web development over time
my 20 year dev journey and how things
were different back then to how they are
now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I love community events cuz they bring
together people from all over the globe
they enable everyone to feel welcome and
make them feel that they're a part of
the community and community events are
also so special for up-and-coming
developers if you are new in the
community getting a lot of exposure to
new things just finding new people that
you can connect with and then you can
get like a new opportunity from that
then these events are like they're like
homecomings and reunions for us to like
sit and actually meet these people that
we talk to online all day and keep those
friendships and connections alive the
people who spend their time come at
these events preparing for these events
are the people who are so excited and
passionate about these topics and I feel
like this is such a family and the more
I come to these kinds of events the more
that family grows and grows
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't know cssm you
maybe appreciate it
in fact they're worth
it's definitely felt
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you for everything
CSS community I'm extremely honored to
have been part of the CSS come for you
and being able to have such a great
happy event with you community so that's
it that was the last yes as fun for you
and we're out of here
and I will miss it the handing it back
to you with this and I'm excited to see
what's next
[Music]